let's talk about the mistakes people
make when they do prolonged fasting
out of all the things you can do
prolonged fasting is probably one of the
most important things you can do for
your health for your ability to avoid
cancer
for anti-aging
for strengthening your immune system
[Music]
for your brain to grow new brain cells
for any type of chronic health condition
that involves inflammation like
autoimmune disease like celiac and
digestive inflammatory diseases so hands
down prolonged fasting just takes your
health results to the next level
it's way more powerful than even regular
intermittent fasting and whether you're
doing a 48 hour uh fast or 72 hours or
even seven days this video is going to
give you some insights on some big
problems you can avoid if you just have
the data now there's two main things
that you need to know
uh when you do these prolonged fast
number one insulin becomes very very
sensitive okay if you had insulin
resistance
now you're going to have insulin
sensitivity so insulin is going to be
very very sensitive and that means
if you do
carbohydrates to break your fast you are
going to make a huge mistake so let's
talk about mistake number one breaking
your fast with carbohydrates
and i'm also including fruit and berries
you don't want to do that
because here you are you generated these
stem cells right ready to turn into
things to help repair your body maybe
you want to repair your immune system
if there's too many carbohydrates
especially when you break the fast
guess what that stem cell could turn
into
a fat cell and that's the last type of
new cell that you want in your body
we want to reserve these stem cells for
very important
recovery and repair
tissue like your joints or your bone
marrow or your thymus gland things like
that so recently i noticed that my voice
was uh kind of cracking up kind of
becoming a little deeper
so i just started fasting immediately
just to to make sure that my immune
system had everything it needed to
recover and rejuvenate and it was great
because whatever happened in my body i
overcame it within a day and a half and
things were back to normal but the
effects of fasting on your immune system
is very very powerful i mean there are
people that have autoimmune diseases
like
serious diseases with massive
inflammation that do a prolonged fast
and pull right out of this condition and
it just goes in remission of course they
can't say they cured it but they can say
it went into remission which basically
you kind of cured it i mean fasting
right now is even being researched
by
people that are going to do long term
travel into space they found that
fasting could potentially protect you
against solar radiation as you're
traveling to mars
i mean it's just mind-blowing now you
can do steamed veggies you can do
fermented vegetables which i highly
recommend i also recommend bone broth a
little kefir
an egg
but other than that
keep it really really small
if you consume a good amount of carbs
right after a prolonged fast what's
going to also happen is you're going to
have this
massive shift of potassium
inside the cell and out of the blood so
we're going to remove potassium out of
the blood and you're going to end up
with a severe
hypokalemic situation which is low
potassium in the blood
and that's going to increase your pulse
rate you can get sick it's actually
quite dangerous so this is called the
refeeding syndrome where you just eat
too fast especially carbohydrates
because it throws off your electrolytes
remember insulin is very very sensitive
and so insulin is going to also take on
some of these nutrients and it's no
longer resistant so everything is a
whole different situation
all right number two mistake um doing
intense exercise or a lot of physical
work right out of the gate doing
prolonged fasting okay you don't want to
do that your body has just been through
a lot of autophagy repair recycling
rejuvenation and you don't want to add
that extra stress at this point so it's
not actually beneficial to do
high level exercise when you're
in prolonged fasting or when you come
out of prong prolonged fasting now when
you're doing intermittent fasting
absolutely but not when you're doing
prolonged fasting it can be very
stressful to the heart
who knows also if you have enough
electrolytes for the heart
some people don't even take any
supplements while they're fasting which
i disagree with so the only point is
when you're doing prolonged fasting
let your body recover heal rejuvenate
all right number three
you don't want to make the mistake that
i made by over eating
coming out of a prolonged fast okay
the temptation is there you haven't
eaten for
days and now
there's all this food and you you might
start eating and going wow i
i really miss food and i just start
getting uh wrapped up in that you don't
want to do that because you have to
realize that the digestive system
has gone asleep all right it's a sleep
and you have to wake it up
slowly
i mean you have all sorts of
enzymes that are not going to be ready
to help you digest
acids
bile salts
maybe even there might even be some
missing microbes i don't know but the
point is if you overload the system and
eat too much
you can get either edema in your body or
you could get diarrhea
or get extremely nauseous and
uncomfortable
like i did so i've learned the hard way
you don't want to overeat you want to
have just a small little thing
regardless of the temptation
and then wait uh several hours
and do another small thing okay and then
wait maybe five hours and then have kind
of a smaller meal but maybe a little bit
bigger and that's it for the whole day
and then the next day have a little bit
more so you want to gradually go into
this
so it's very very
easy
for your body
the next mistake uh is doing apple cider
vinegar coming off of a prolonged fast
in fact you don't want to do apple cider
vinegar when you're doing a prolonged
fast in the middle of it or at the end
of it why because you are in a very
strong
ketogenic state
and ketones are acidic
so your ph is going to be pretty acidic
so adding more apple cider vinegar can
make you more acidic
instead a better way to deal with that
is to
take some baking soda which is alkaline
and you can mix like one fourth of a
teaspoon in some water
and drink that
that will help to neutralize the acidity
okay so that would be one thing you
could do but also realize that the
vegetables will help alkalize the body
as well
all right the fifth mistake is to
instead of doing like real food
you are doing uh protein powders not
natural not good
remember protein powders usually are
low fat they're they're hardly any fat
and that's going to have a greater
effect on insulin if you take a look at
the insulin index okay i have this in my
book the thing that's the highest is
whey protein powder you want to consume
actual protein with its own fat like an
egg for example but just a very small
amount but i wanted to just create this
short video to kind of give you
some really important things to watch
out for when you do prolonged fasting
you need to do prolonged fasting because
the benefits and also you just need to
know what to break your fast with that
you're going to be safe all right if you
haven't seen my other video on prolonged
fasting i put it up right here check it
out